[Music]
a very good morning and afternoon to
everyone virtually
welcome to today's webinar
impact of novel laminar wash on nuclei
retention and other downstream
applications a sarah vance story
i'm christina dewell of labruts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by curios
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit curios.com
now let's get started
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
i would now like to welcome our speakers
david cadwallader
research scientist sarah vance
and sashi ponolagu research scientist
curios
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top left of your screen
david you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction um
yes so my name is david canwolada
i am a research scientist at cerevance
and i'm going to talk today
about the impact that
the laminar wash technology from keuriox
biosystems has had on
the nuclear retention
and other downstream applications for
our uses at ceravans
so there's kind of four main parts to
the talk today uh first i'll just give
you a brief introduction to sarah vance
as a company and our netseq platform
um i'll talk about the
uh how the netseq platform is
underpinned by
uh nuclei isolation and preparation and
how the efficiency of that preparation
is uh limited by centrifuge based
washing methods
um
and so how we went about
tackling those efficiency issues
by
integrating the laminar wash hg2000
system into our protocols um and how
that improved both our preparation
efficiencies and also enable us to make
uh significant financial savings
so ceremonies is a private
pharmaceutical company
and we're able to highly selectively
identify novel targets using our
proprietary nuclear enriched transcript
sort sequencing platform or
netsig for short
so we develop new therapies for
neurological and psychiatric diseases
that work through
novel mechanisms of action
and we kind of
where we place ourselves is because the
human brain is is is a very complex
organism very complicated organ
so that adds in an extra layer of
difficulty in identifying
differentially or selectively expressed
proteins um to target
with uh with new
therapies
now our netsig platform is
uh as mentioned is based on nuclei
isolation and preparation
and we do that using we isolate those
from
human post-mortem uh cns tissue and so
obviously we need to have a significant
amount of tissue and our
brain tissue collection currently
um consists of over 12 000 disease and
control
tissue samples spanning over 50
different brain regions and with a wide
range of donor ages
and we've
been assembling and building this and
continue to develop and grow this
collection um through working with 21
global brain banks
so
fundamentally
netseq allows us to
identify and sort
cell type specific nuclei populations
from this processed human postmortem cms
cns tissue
and these
cell type specific populations enable us
to make
deep transcriptomic comparisons between
our disease and our control tissue
and we can
use these comparisons to
expose underlying pathways that would be
difficult to to to see in
more uh
simplistic or different ipsc or animal
models
so that's kind of a lot of words for
next seek and this is a bit more of a
pictorial overview of the processes
involved
um so as mentioned we start with our our
postmortem cns tissue so these are
snap frozen samples and we're able to
take small
small tissue dissections that are region
specific and from those we can
homogenize the tissue from the
homogeneous we're able to isolate and
fix the nuclei before labeling them
usually with antibodies occasionally
with riboprobes
and then we're able to
identify and sort those cell type
specific nuclei populations
at the cytometer using fluorescent
activated uh nuclei sorting or
fluorescent activated cell sort as it's
shown in the image above um
from those populations we can then
extract and sequence the rna to generate
our cell type specific transcriptome
which can then be used for downstream
analyses
so what i'm going to focus on today is
the work that our group run
and that's really this middle part of
the platform so going from the small
tissue dissections
through to homogenizing it uh fixing the
nuclei labeling the nuclei and sorting
the nuclei into their
cell type specific populations
and
within the work that i've done i'm
really going to highlight where the
ht2000 has made a big difference to our
work and that's in this middle section
here
so focusing on the antibody labeling
side of things
so
typically we uh label
our nuclei with indirect antibody
labeling so we would um
we'd incubate our sample with a
target primary antibody that is does not
have any any uh fluorochromes attached
and then we would have a second
incubation with our species-specific
secondary antibodies that contain our
desired fluorochromes because that gives
us a bit more flexibility when designing
our panels
so
before the ht2000 came along
we would do
centrifuge wash based
cycles so we would have our 60 minute
incubation with our primary antibodies
and then
after that in order to make sure we
remove any unbound antibody to give us
the cleanest signal at the cytometer
we would run three rounds of
three-minute spins in the centrifuge
which
is you know
there's nine minutes of spin time but
then there's all the other time in
between
so you've got two
unload the the centrifuge remove the
supernatant
resuspend the pellet
reload it into the centrifuge and so on
and do that three times and then we've
got our
secondary incubation so another half an
hour before repeating the wash cycle so
as you can see from my my estimated
summing there that's quite a significant
amount of time
and that kind of feeds into some of our
where we're limited by the use of the
centrifuge within this uh platform
so
it is it is a lot of time as it was on
the previous slide there it's you know
two to two and a half hours of work in
the afternoon um
and that's that scales so if you're only
handling say three or four samples it's
quite quick to take them out the
centrifuge remove the supernatant across
those four tubes resuspend those four
pellets reload into the centrifuge but
if you're handling more say we're doing
15 16 samples it's gonna take a lot
longer because you know it's it's fiddly
i put them into the centrifuge let alone
the time taken to handle all of those
and remove all of the supernatant
resuspend all the pellets
so it can take quite a long time if
you're looking to handle a higher number
of samples
we've also got a limit in terms of
how much we can handle per sample
so the the maximum and minimum amount of
nuclei which is is manageable uh within
our within the tube so we use just
standard 1.5 mil ependorfs
and we've found again over a long
period of uh optimization that we can
get away with a maximum of 10 maybe if
you push it 15 million nuclei per tube
um anymore beyond that and the pellet
just becomes quite uh
the top of the the top of the pellet
doesn't uh pack down as tightly and it
gets quite fluffy so as you pet off the
supernatant you run the risk of
losing some of those nuclei as um as the
the tip gets too close
and it's kind of the same at the other
end of the scale so with the minimum
amount
the pellet is so much smaller it's very
fragile
and it doesn't pack down at the bottom
of the tube instead it kind of smears
along
the outside of the tube which again
makes it very difficult
to accurately and carefully remove the
supinator without disturbing the pellet
and risking loss so we've found that if
we want to have if we're only looking at
this tube to have enough to record and
we're not looking to sort so it's for
a compensation control or
an unlabeled control we can get away
with
um
less about half a million five hundred
thousand nuclei in the tube
because we're not as concerned about
making sure we maximize the amount of
nuclei in the sample at the cytometer
however if we want to make sure we've
got enough to sort from and it's you
know it's dependent on the populations
we're sorting
but we don't want to go below about a
million nuclei in the tube to start with
because again you just the smaller it
gets
the more difficult it is to keep that
whole pellet intact and not lose
anything
so this is where the uh the ht2000 came
in
so
on the time front
it makes a big difference so
as opposed to
nine minutes of time of the centrifuge
running plus time in between to remove
the supernatants and resuspend the
pellets you simply
take your 96 well laminar wash plate
load it onto the instrument hit start
and in under five minutes it's washed
the entire plate and
the wells are ready for you to spike the
secondary antibody in for the next
incubation or if it's at the end to
to resuspend the nuclei and filter them
through to go to the cytometer so it's
it's a significant time saving on that
front it's gone from 15 to 30 minutes
for a wash cycle to five minutes
um
and in the same way it doesn't that wash
time doesn't scale with the number of
samples so it's a the laminar wash plate
is a on a 96 while plate format
so
it takes the exact same amount of time
for uh
you to wash
25 samples on the plate as it would do
if you wanted to wash 75 samples on the
plate it's that same sub five minute
wash time for an equivalent
um
wash cycle to our three by three minutes
in the centrifuge
we've also tested in terms of the
limit of the nuclei
per tube or per sample
and we've found that at the top end of
the scale we've tested as high as 8
million nuclei per well without seeing
any observed reduction in
nuclei at the cytometer
um so it's a little lower but it's you
know
the the difference between eight and ten
at this scale is is fairly small
um but at the other end of the scale
when we're talking about the minimum
limits that's where we've made a big big
gain
so if we're looking for control we can
go as as low as a hundred thousand
nuclei
in there and have an equivalent amount
of nuclei to record for our
sample at the cytometer as we would do
with 500 000 nuclei
in our centrifuge based protocol
and if we want enough for the to sort
from the sample again we don't make as
big a relative saving but again we can
go from one million required in our
centrifuge
to
half a million nuclei in the laminar
wash plate and have an equivalent amount
of nuclei
to sort
at the
at the end of the process
so again for those of you who are a bit
more like me in a bit more visually
minded to put that
in perspective
there is a slight decrease with the
laminar wash at the top end
um
but at the at the lower end if we're
wanting to sort we can we
can put much less in we can we can put
in half the amount and get out the same
amount at the end of the process
and for the um
for the control again even we can put in
20
of what we would previously needed to
put in and have
a viable and equivalent
sample at the cytometer
so that gives us a lot of flexibility
when we're we're working with postmortem
human tissue so we never know
how many nuclei we're going to get out
of a particular piece of tissue until
we've
uh homogenized the tissue and isolated
the nuclei fixed them and had an
opportunity to to count
a representative sample of it
so
you know this gives us a lot more
flexibility with what we're able to do
and just as importantly as all of that
in fact i'd say more importantly than
any of that is the laminar wash
technology is
very gentle with our nuclei
so we've seen no apparent change in the
rna integrity or the resultant rna
sequence
data quality that we get out
uh at the end of the platform at the end
of our netsig platform
and so crucially we've been able to to
introduce
this technology to our protocols without
having an impact on our our the the
quality of data that we are able to
produce using this
so again to put it in perspective
with a centrifuge two to two and a half
hours
whereas
with the laminar wash
it's 100 minutes you know it's a little
over an hour and a half which is a you
know that's saving
20 minutes
50 minutes if we're going even if we're
handling lots and lots of samples it
could even save us an hour or more which
is very important as i'm sure
i'm sure all of you like me have a lot
of issues with finding time to do you
know everyone's favorite work of
returning to their desk and continuing
on with their data analysis that
they're hiding away from in the lab
so kind of to sum up so far
we've made significant time savings with
the introduction of the hg2000
it's given us a greater amount of
flexibility
by reducing the
nuclear nuclei input that we need to
have the same output
and it's managed to do all this while
maintaining the same
standard of high quality data that we're
able to generate so the next question is
can we can we make can we save some
money with it too
so
our centrifuge based protocol
um
means uh requires that we
label our nuclear with the antibodies in
a 500 microliter reaction volume
and
our antibody panels we've optimized over
quite a long period of time the ones we
have in use commonly
and
we
typically describe the um
antibody concentration that we use as a
as a fraction so
90 or 95
of all our antibodies we would add as
either one in 250 where we'd have two
microliters and a 500 microliter
reaction volume or 10125 where we'd have
four microliters
however because of the size of the wells
on the laminar wash plates that we use
with the ht2000 system um we've had to
scale that reaction volume down to 50
microliters
which means obviously we had to to go
back and re-optimize the antibody
concentrations for our established
panels to
make sure that we were able to
continue and have the same quality of
signal at the cytometer
so i'm just going to talk you through
some of the early optimization work that
we did when we first
started testing this on the ht2000
and in red we've got our centrifuge wash
sample so this is our control this is
labeled in exactly the same way that we
always would do and we always had done
before
so we've got antibody b on the x-axis
here
and typically we would add antibody b
we'd have four microliters
um so that would be at a dilution of one
in one two five
um in blue
we have our first condition that we
tested on the laminar wash plate where
we
maintain the same
dilution factor so we added the antibody
again at one in one two five so in this
case we added 0.4 microliters into our
50 microliter
well and
you can see it's kind of we're still
seeing the same population
um but the separation's not as clear
whereas
at the other end of the scale we also
tested reducing the dilution fracture
and maintaining the same
absolute volume of antibody added now in
green here option b is actually we've
slightly reduced the
um
absolute volume of the antibody added so
we halved it from four microliters to
two microliters so at a dilution factor
of one in 25
um because this was the this was the the
best quality signal that we saw so again
this
uh negative population that's circled
and the uh top left of the the
population actually
across all three conditions
the uh the percentage of this population
is incredibly similar it's 5.3 at its
lowest and 5.45 at its highest so it's
not a huge difference but
crucially what is different is the level
of separation that we're seeing from the
main
positive population to the right of it
and it's it's a it's a clearer
separation in option b than we saw in
option a
so this was kind of the first round of
testing that we did
and we took that information and we
conducted further rounds of optimization
across multiple antibody panels so we've
got another example here where this time
we've got antibody c
on the x axis again in red is our
centrifuge wash control
where this time we would add two
microliters
um into our 500 microliter reaction
volume for a dilution factor of one in
250
and again
in blue we have option a where we've
reduced the antibody volume from two
microliters to 0.5 microliters
and in green we focus more on reducing
the
dilution factor again as before this
green one actually we've reduced the
absolute volume again by 50 and this
produced the cleanest separation so
again these percentages of these
populations are actually very similar so
this large positive population is
sitting around about 40
um for both the red and the blue it's a
little higher in the green in fact at 45
but it's fairly consistent what is
different is the
the separation of that positive
population from the negative population
in the blue
it's less
there's a there's not as strong a signal
and
what separation there is is slightly
messier it's not got clean break it
shows up a bit more clearly on the
contour plots but it's still
it's not quite as good as we could get
and it's not quite as good indeed as we
did get with our option b where we've
reduced uh the absolute volume by 50
and that was the tail that we saw across
all our uh primary antibody optimization
was
that
reducing the absolute volume of antibody
added from our centrifuge
uh
wash panel to our laminar wash panel
produced the most consistent and the the
strongest signal overall
however as i said
90 odd percent of our um antibody
labeling is indirect antibody labeling
so we had to repeat these titration
experiments with our secondary
antibodies
and once again we've got on the left
hand side we've got our red
plot is our centrifuge wash control plot
and we saw as with the primary
antibodies that a 50
uh edition a 50 reduction sorry of our
secondary antibodies
produced the best results overall so the
cleanest separation and the strongest
signal
so that's meant that we were able to
stand we were able to say okay we'll
take our our
centrifuge wash
based antibody panels that we've
optimized for for this protocol and we
can reduce the
volume of antibody that we had for use
with our laminar wash protocol by 50
so we've halved the amount of antibody
used
and
that's meant that we can make a
significant savings in the the uh our
spending on antibodies so just from
those antibodies that we've discussed so
far that i've shown on those slides so
far where we've got three different
primary antibodies and the corresponding
secondary antibodies i've just shown you
an approximate spending that we would
make on those
per year
in pound sterling
based on our current usage and then the
second row we're showing how much we'd
save by halving our use for the our use
of them by labeling the nuclear instead
in the laminar wash plates
and across just those three primary
antibodies and those three secondary
antibodies we'd save over three and a
half thousand pounds so
from that that's you know that's a lot
that's a significant amount of money
from
three three antibodies and three
secondary antibodies
you know
uh extrapolate that across
other panels that we've run and i'm sure
the same for you if you if you have a
similar thing
that
that adds up to to a a significant
amount of money across the course of a
year and
as we all know antibodies are expensive
most things in science are expensive so
the more you can find ways to save this
money without importantly without
compromising
um your results
the better and
what we've seen is that
labeling our antibody labeling our
nuclei sorry on
laminar wash plates
across time has shown consistency
so this consistency as well it's
important to note
is true regardless of the operator
so unlike with a centrifuge wash based
protocol where
each individual user will maybe
take a little bit more or a little bit
less of the supernatant out and risk
losing a little bit more nuclei
um
unlike that whoever the user is they
just pick up the plate they put it in
the instrument they press start and the
instrument does it the same every single
time
so this consistency is true all the way
through and i've just taken a couple of
examples here of uh
nuclei that were labeled with the same
antibodies
um and were the nuclear were isolated
and prepped from matching tissue
dissections what i mean by that is
they were
both these pieces of tissue were
dissected from the same donor and from
the same
brain slice across the same brain region
uh but they were done seven months apart
so you can see there is you know there's
a slight difference in how they show up
but that's because i've checked back
these are actually recorded on two
different instruments um so you will see
a slight difference in where that
negative population is sitting on those
um scales but crucially uh the signal
looks the same and the pop the
percentage of the populations is very
similar 4.7
uh on the right hand side for that
highlighted population in the circle and
in the left-hand side it's slightly
higher at 5.3
which you would expect to see slight
differences when you're not working with
the same
um initial nuclei prep but you are
working from
the same
starting piece of parent tissue that we
then sub dissected from
so to go back and answer my question
can we also save some money yes we can
we've been able to reduce our antibody
consumption by 50 while maintaining the
same
um high quality
signal that we see at the cytometer
so
to sum up really
by integrating the uh laminar hg2000
into our
nuclei labeling protocol we've been able
to save time we've been able to save
money on uh reagents we've been able to
have a greater flexibility where we're
working with
a limited sample input so we've a
limited number of nuclear that we get
from each
tissue dissection and we've been able to
do all of this
without any uh difference in the high
quality of data that we've been able to
put out
um so
that's my presentation i'd just like to
say thank you for listening and i'd like
to thank um kuriock's biosystems for
giving me the platform to talk to you
it's been really great to work with them
and give us a chance to enhance our
nuclear preparation capabilities
there is a second section um to this
talk presented by curiosity systems
themselves
they do a lot of in-house work on cell
and more recently nuclear biology
obviously taking uh making full use of
all the advantages that the laminar wash
technology gives them
i believe they're about to show us some
of their data generated to address
some of the newer demands
they've seen for nuclear retention uh
especially from a um
a biophysical and a true to biology
perspective so once again thank you
hi everyone i'm sashi i'm a research
scientist with curios and today i'm here
to talk about how lamina wash can help
you retain the native sub-population in
your heteroskinos samples during sample
prep
but before that i'm going to talk about
laminar wash
so how does laminar wash technology work
so basically it is a centrifugalist
washing system which uses our
proprietary plate
the samples are plated on the 96 valve
plate design without walls
and the samples are settled at the
bottom of the well
the samples can be nuclei or cells
as you can see from the video
the debris or any unbound antibodies is
then washed away by laminar flow which
is a turbulence free
washing technology
and by serial dilution at the end of the
wash we are able to collect samples that
are cleaner and stress free
with his data um at servants where they
actually worked with bulk isolated
nuclei they demonstrated with laminar
wash they attained the higher nuclear
retention compared to centrifuge which
allows for smaller starting material and
this is particularly
useful when they are working with rare
tissue samples and they also use laminar
wash to attain similar or better
staining of nuclei with 50 less
antibodies
so this translates to savings on
reagents and costs
to about three thousand and six hundred
dollars per annum and when they are
looking at five marker panel
besides all these um savings and
retention viva are at kurioks trying to
identify other areas where laminar wash
can help the research scientists and we
decided on three particular areas we
wanted to see how laminar wash can
maintain the ratios of subpopulations in
a heterogeneous sample even after
multiple washes and we wanted to see the
recovery rate after several washes and
we were wondering how efficient debris
removal was going to be and if you're
wondering why this is even important
well with single cell sequencing
becoming more important and interesting
right now the scientists want to look at
the whole tissue like brain or even
blood samples
these samples have different cell
subsets
so um being able to retain the
natural uh the native sub-population uh
frequency will allow scientists to
identify
any
um
subtle difference in these populations
um
which may arise due to disease or
interventions
so how do we plan to check out these
areas we have a plan of action we are
going to mix nuclei isolated from
differently sized cells to represent a
heterogeneous population and then we
want to wash them to mimic downstream
processing that goes on in labs
then later we will determine the
subpopulation integrity debris removal
and recovery
so here is my methodology for retention
of heterogeneous nuclei samples we use
b16 f10 which is a murine melanoma cell
line
it
represents a medium size nuclei in size
from 20 to 30 microns and we use u97 a
human monocytic cell line to represent
at a smaller range at 10 microns so we
performed nuclei isolation following the
10x genomics protocol and unfixed nuclei
was then spiked to
provide a one is to one mixture so the
mixture was then washed uh with
centrifuge or laminar wash and on
centrifuge we did a 30 minute washing so
the sample was then acquired on celeste
together with counting bits
so we identified the sizing gate using
the individual samples and then we did
the singlet gating for each
subpopulation and then we looked at the
w positive nuclei
samples
so here i am presenting my tree
conditions lamina wash centrifuge and
unwashed so if you were to look at b16
f10 sub population it ranged at 28 to 29
frequency but for u937 you will see it
changed changed from 36 to 43
or centrifuge and this data was further
reconfirmed by looking at the absolute
um
count of nuclei so the ratio of u-937 uh
to b16f10 was actually 1.2 for laminar
wash which was very close to unwashed at
1.1
for centrifuge it was around 1.4
so the retention of u937 is actually not
significantly significantly different
across the conditions but when we look
at b16 f10 nuclide the retention was
much lower for centrifuge and this is
how we were able to show that laminar
wash allows better analysis of samples
by retaining the rest of populations
next we looked at debris removal in
tumor samples which are much dirtier
than the cell lines so we had a
xenograph model and the
single tumor cells were collected by
mechanical disruption then we performed
nuclei isolation following the 10x
genomics protocol we did the washing by
centrifuge and laminar wash then the
samples were acquired by uh flow cider
ventricular on celeste
and when we looked at these samples we
could see the non-dappy events which are
considered our debris it was much lower
for cent laminar wash when compared to
centrifuge in fact
centrifuge seems to introduce the brave
and compared to and wash
basically lamina wash provides us
cleaner samples for downstream analysis
so here we identify the problems and i
can show you that laminar wash gives you
benefits it allows you to retain the
frequency of the subpopulations in
samples so allowing a better
representation of samples for sequencing
and even flow analysis and also lemon
wash has better recovery rate
it requires less starting materials so
if you are working with pressure samples
let me know which is a better bet and
lamina wash has better debris removal so
you have cleaner sample for downstream
analysis
basically
laminar wash allows you to have better
retention of rare heterogeneous samples
during sample preparation so if you are
curious about curios yet uh check out
our website for
further applications and if you want you
can check out the video for the laminar
wash
methodology and please uh drop a demo
request form if you would like to work
with us
and um we look forward to helping you
with your centrifugal washing experience
thank you for your time and now we will
move on to questions
thank you david and sashi for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live q a portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
any questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started david i'm going
to start with you
when working with nuclei and prepping
for sorting
what are the major concerns that you had
for example cell state
so
we're
two main concerns really and kind of the
first one and the one that is always at
the front of our minds when we're
handling
uh our samples from the from the frozen
tissue onwards is we want to
keep rna degradation to it to a minimum
because our you know our platform is
based on the
quality of the rna sequencing data that
we get out at the end
so we want to make sure that that rna is
in the best possible condition
throughout the process so that when we
get the cell type specific
nuclei populations
out from the sorter that we've
we've given ourselves the best shot at
generating good quality rna-seq data
but also on the other hand we kind of
do want to make sure that like
it's not an unmanageable
protocol in terms of
the the time span so you will see other
examples in the literature of um
antibody incubations taking place at
four degrees
celsius overnight
but then
because it we do a lot of indirect
labeling that would mean that's a a two
plus day protocol whereas
shorter room temperature incubations
we're still able to get good quality uh
rnac data out while meaning that we can
conduct our entire nuclei isolation
labeling protocol in a single day ready
for sorting on the next day
our second
concern has been just about maintaining
a consistency
in terms of the
quality of antibody labeling that we see
between
nuclei preps
[Music]
and just making sure that again
what we see
what the signal we see on what uh from a
panel in in one donor is is
translatable across
multiple
donor tissues
thanks david sashi let's come over to
you and we have some great questions
coming in
let's start with this one besides
imaging of nuclei
do you have
other experiments to show nuclei
integrity
um so yes for nuclei integrity there are
actually different ways to determine it
but for the purpose of this experiment
we only performed microscopic imaging uh
but we know customers like to sample the
supernatant for free rna and free
nucleic acids
by looking at nadro or even
use the
cubic floor meter
very good let's stick with you and how
about this one
do you have any insights into isolated
nuclei preps
from other methods for example ffpe
types
yeah so personally we have tried using
fresh cells and
frozen pbmcs but
with the um
ffpe types right um i don't think it'll
be much different once we have these
single cells out we can do the nuclear
insulation in a similar manner and then
continue with the washing it wouldn't
have any other effects
thanks sashi
david let's jump back to you
besides improving the sample preparation
steps through laminar wash
what else did you try previously
so we're kind of in a you know always
continually looking to try and refine
and improve
our protocols and especially look to try
and
maximize
both our time
efficiency but also our
nuclear retention efficiency
so alongside um
looking at curios and their laminar wash
technology we've made small tweaks in
kind of timings of how and when
um
we transfer nuclei between different
tube types during the earlier stages in
the
isolation protocol
and then we've you know we keep an eye
on on other new technology too so we've
um
for example we've demoed automated cell
counters to try and see if we can save
time there
however of the various examples we've
tried they're either
not set up to effectively count nuclei
they're more kind of cell counters that
we've tried to see if we can we can
adapt and adjust
um or they they do work and they do
count the nuclei well
but the
you know the the the price of the
instrument is is too much for us to to
justify in terms of the relatively small
amount of time we would save by by
introducing that into our protocol
thanks david i'm gonna have another one
for you here
what are your experiences with the
retention rate of nuclei with laminar
wash for example how do you measure that
so that was kind of
that was the reason we first looked at
curiosity's product in the first place
was looking to to improve our nuclear
retention
especially when working with
smaller
nuclei input
so that was a lot of our very very early
demo work
was looking at comparing
um low nuclei input amounts between
laminar washing centrifuge wash based um
labeling protocols so we we tried it
sort of a range from sort of as low as
uh 50 000 nuclei up to about 500 000
nucleoid
um and just performed
uh in this case sort of direct antibody
labeling with with conjugated antibodies
uh and washed them with our two
two different methods and then just
recorded
everything in the sample on the
cytometers
to see how much sample was left
at the end of the labeling protocol and
actually it was quite a stark difference
so when uh comparing the centrifuge
washed
uh sample to the laminar washer samples
um the average fold change was a little
over 1.5 so quite a big
leap up in terms of retention
and we were also able to see
that there was a a smaller increase but
still a significant increase in that we
saw a seven percent increase in the
um percentage of single nuclei
um in comparison to the the centrifuge
wash so again we saw a slight reduction
in
both the the
droplets on the cytometer containing
aggregated nuclei or um droplets
containing debris so both you know both
from a sample retention and a
sample quality point of view on the the
cytometer we were seeing improvements um
with the lemon or wash
okay great david thank you for that
sashi
question over for you an unbiased wash
is important
what other parameters can we optimize on
the laminar wash platform
yeah so we can always optimize the
incubation time the incubation volume we
can also
optimize on the washing flooring to make
sure we have an efficient wash while
retaining the nuclei at the best
possible optimum
amount
thanks ashi and we have time for just a
few more i'm going to go one more with
you and we'll close with david have you
looked into free dna rna removal
yes we have in fact we recently had a
demo with our client they were using
oligopoles and after washing they looked
at the supernatant
they used the
cure b fluorometer to identify any free
nucleic acid
so it was really
a new way instead of just looking at our
you know
flow cytometry or any other way they
were using this fluorometer too quickly
um without any gel analysis or anything
they were quickly just using the
fluorometer
you sashi and david this question came
in a few times so i do want to end with
this one so i can answer multiple
attendees
how many antibody savings were you able
to save for example cost per assay or
cost per wealth
well i i kind of i did i addressed it a
bit in the slides um
so
we were able to to overall make a
a general reduction for all our primary
and secondary antibodies
or we were able to reduce the amount we
would add to each reaction by 50
um and i kind of i've pulled out some of
those numbers there
um so for
quite an extreme example that antibody b
i was talking about um
i i estimate that over the course of a
year at our current usage we spend about
uh a little over three and a half
thousand pound just on that one antibody
so i think that the number is closer to
three thousand six hundred pound pounds
so in just that one example by using
half the amount of it we were able to
effectively
um
half
our costs there so we're able to save
um nearly 2 thousand pounds so one
thousand eight hundred pound uh just in
that one example another less extreme
example there was was antibody c but
again over the course of a year we'd
save uh slightly over 500 pounds on that
one example
so overall it adds up to thousands and
thousands of pounds um across all our
our different panels
sure
thank you david and sasha david thank
you both for joining us today i'd like
to give you the opportunity to give any
final comments to our audience
uh i think for me it's just uh you know
again i said it at the end of my slides
but thank you for listening and then
again i'll repeat my thank you to to
cure as well for giving us the
opportunity to to present some of the
work that our group have done um with
them to to enhance our
our our throughput and our our um
capabilities so yeah uh just thank you
yes and i would also like to thank
for giving us this beautiful
presentation sharing all this great data
and again um
we just want to reiterate the savings
and benefits with laminar wash um it is
also very good for yourself or sneak
life that you're doing they are
maintained stress free
so yeah thank you
thank you again david and sashi for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor curios for underwriting
today's educational webcast
now before we go i would like to thank
the audience for joining us and for
their interesting questions there were
quite a few questions we were unable to
get to so those questions we do not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now
take care everybody have a great day
you